J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Hello tout le monde, ravi de vous retrouver et désolé pour ce mois passé sans épisode.
Déménagement, séparation et bien sûr mon éternelle procrastination, le genre de trucs qui font que voilà, c'est compliqué de produire du podcast.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour passer septante minutes avec Thomas Dermine, secrétaire d'État à la Relance.
Il a sorti il y a peu un livre : Wallonie-Flandre, Par-delà les clichés, ce qui nous a donné l'occasion d'avoir une discussion vraiment intéressante sur les éternelles questions,
les éternelles frictions Nord-Sud qui animent les débats politiques en Belgique depuis des décennies.
Je vous présente aussi mes excuses pour le petit parasite audio que vous avez sans doute remarqué en début d'enregistrement.
Il finit par s'en aller, ne vous inquiétez pas. Je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Thomas Dermine. Bonjour Thomas.
Bonjour Guillaume.
Thomas, tu es secrétaire d'État à la Relance au sein du gouvernement fédéral, au sein de la coalition Vivaldi. Et on se parle aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la sortie de ton nouveau livre : Wallonie-Flandre, Par-delà les clichés,
que tu sors donc ce mois-ci, c'est juste—
Oui, il est sorti fin du mois d'octobre.
Ok, oui, ça fait exactement un mois du coup.
Exactement.
Livre qui aborde donc la fameuse question communautaire, la fameuse question, toute une série de clichés que tu abordes, que tu déconstruis, je veux dire.
On aura l'occasion d'explorer tout ça ensemble. Mais avant de se lancer au cœur de ce sujet-là, je voulais poser deux, trois questions sur ta personne, au sujet de ton histoire.
Tu es ministre, je l'ai dit, secrétaire d'État à la Relance. Es-tu—
Et sous-ministre hein.
Sous-ministre, oui, voilà, ministre cœur.
Oui, c'est selon, selon.
Et donc, oui, on est aujourd'hui, en fait, on se parle à Solvay, pour le cent vingtième anniversaire de la SBS.
Parcours un petit peu remarquable. D'ailleurs, dans ton livre, tu le retraces vite fait en début de livre, socialiste carolo.
Tu es rapidement parti étudier en Flandre, puis à Solvay, puis étudier à Harvard. Tu t'es envolé très vite. Est-ce que tu ne serais pas un des plus jeunes ministres de l'histoire de Belgique ?
Non, je pense qu'il y en a plusieurs qui ont été aussi dans leur trentaine dans des gouvernements. Mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui, au sein du gouvernement fédéral, je suis le plus jeune.
Sammy Mahdi, je pense, a quelques mois de moins que moi, mais comme il a quitté le gouvernement, j'ai hérité du titre du plus jeune ministre au sein du gouvernement Vivaldi.
Une chose qu'on sent à la lecture de ce livre, c'est— alors, c'est un livre qui, déjà, pour un livre de politicien, est avant tout un livre de solvaisien, j'ai l'impression.
Beaucoup de chiffres, beaucoup de pourcentages, beaucoup de graphiques. Et donc, tu parles un petit peu au début du livre, effectivement, de ton parcours, comment tu as grandi, ici en Belgique.
Et on sent une part d'affect sur notamment la question de l'œil wall. Est-ce que j'ai raison ? Est-ce que c'est une phrase qui, encore aujourd'hui, quand tu l'entends…
Non, c'est vrai que c'est un livre qui est très personnel. Moi, j'ai une histoire personnelle qui n'a rien d'extraordinaire.
J'ai grandi à Charleroi, puis j'ai eu la chance de faire des études à Bruxelles, effectivement, en ingénieur de gestion, d'où mon amour pour les chiffres et les choses qui sont précises et bien construites d'un point de vue analytique.
J'ai commencé ma carrière dans le secteur privé, dans le monde de la consultance.
Et des études en Sciences Po aussi, en plus.
J'ai fait des études en Sciences Po en parallèle où j'ai rencontré une personne qui jouera un rôle très fort à différents moments de ma carrière qui est Paul Magnette, qui était prof d'université avant d'être
politicien tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui.
Puis, j'ai eu l'occasion de m'expatrier, d'étudier aux États-Unis, effectivement, l'administration publique à Harvard, de revenir travailler à Londres.
Et puis, c'est presque un accident en fait, qui a fait que mon ancien prof d'université, Paul Magnette, m'a
rappelé pour travailler avec lui sur des sujets de développement économique à Charleroi, suite à la fermeture de l'usine Caterpillar, qui était un vrai traumatisme.
Et c'était un questionnement très profond chez moi, de dire : tiens, en fait, oui, j'ai grandi dans une ville que j'adore, mais qui n'est pas toujours simple.
Et puis jusqu'ici, je me suis éloigné de ma ville de plus en plus loin, Bruxelles, puis à l'étranger, etc. Et est-ce que je veux maintenant revenir ?
C'était un moment où j'avais un tout petit bébé, je venais d'être papa à ce moment-là.
Et la réflexion, c'était un peu de se dire : bon, je pense qu'on se pose tous beaucoup de questions sur ce qu'on a envie de faire dans la vie,
surtout à cet âge-là, je veux dire, c'était entre la fin de la vingtaine, début de la trentaine et je me suis dit : tiens, est-ce que
je pourrais probablement avoir une chouette vie n'importe où dans le monde ?
Mais voilà, l'endroit où on est est par essence toujours un hasard, mais c'est là qu'on construit ses racines. Et tant qu'à faire de vivre une seule vie, autant vivre une vie où on peut continuer, contribuer à construire quelque chose quelque part.
Donc à ce moment-là, tu étais aux États-Unis alors ?
J'étais à Londres.
À Londres, OK. Donc petite hésitation entre spécifiquement Londres ou ailleurs et—
Non, c'était une hésitation beaucoup plus large. C'est-à-dire que j'ai toujours eu en moi cette envie de travailler dans le monde public au service des autres et des citoyens.
Mais j'ai commencé ma carrière en faisant quelque chose d'autre. Donc quand j'étais à Londres, on avait lancé une boîte, une start-up dans le monde technologique.
On venait d'être financé par un grand joueur de l'assurance pour développer notre produit, notre start-up. C'était super, je faisais ça avec un copain.
Et puis j'ai eu cet appel pour revenir travailler à Charleroi. Et donc c'était un grand cas de conscience, mais je ne regrette absolument pas aujourd'hui.
Et ce qui est marrant, c'est que la boîte en question, elle existe toujours. Maintenant, ils ont presque deux cents personnes qui travaillent dans cette entreprise-là.
Mais j'ai aucun regret de me dire : est-ce que si je serais resté, j'aurais été plus heureux de travailler sur ce projet-là ?
Non, j'ai vraiment l'impression, et c'est une chance de faire un boulot qui m'épanouit avec des chouettes collaborateurs sur des projets dans lesquels je crois au service des citoyens et c'est—
Et tu parlais d'une conviction, vraiment d'une motivation à travailler dans le secteur public. Précisément, qu'est-ce qui a amené ça ?
Il y a une interview qui est, je pense, une des plus belles interviews de Jacques Brel où il dit, et je pense qu'il parle lui-même de sa jeunesse et il dit qu'on construit tous ses rêves dans l'enfance.
Et puis on passe une partie de l'âge adulte, finalement, à, il le formule de façon beaucoup plus élégante, mais à
combler des frustrations ou des rêves ou des quêtes, pour reprendre le nom d'un titre de Jacques Brel, défini dans son enfance.
Et moi, y a quelque chose de ça. Je suis un gamin de Charleroi, j'ai grandi dans le centre-ville de Charleroi dans les années nonante qui étaient marquées par un contexte social pas facile, contexte politique qui n'était pas simple.
Et donc oui, je pense que
tous les combats sont beaux à être menés, mais moi, c'est ce combat-là qui m'a animé, le combat pour le développement économique de la Wallonie, pour lutter contre la fatalité, pour montrer que si on avait des difficultés,
c'est pas parce que les gens sont plus nuls ou plus fainéants, mais que voilà, comme dans beaucoup de choses dans la vie, il y a beaucoup d'autres facteurs qui jouent.
Tu parles donc de t'occuper du développement économique de Charleroi et puis de la Wallonie. Est-ce qu'il y a eu à un moment donné chez toi une hésitation entre travailler au niveau communal, régional, aujourd'hui au niveau fédéral ?
Est-ce que tu retrouves cette ambition initiale que tu avais pour le développement économique de Charleroi et la Wallonie ?
Non, parce que je pense qu'on peut, en politique, contribuer à différents niveaux. Ce qui compte, c'est pas tellement le niveau où on est, mais c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait des responsabilités qui nous sont données.
Et la différence, je pense, dans le politique par rapport à des carrières qu'on a dans le monde privé, c'est qu'elles sont par essence très peu prédictives.
Donc il y a un cycle électoral, mais il y a aussi toute une série d'aléas de la vie qui font que parfois, c'est très difficile de faire des plans.
Mhm. Donc, je le disais, dans ce livre, tu t'attaques à une série de, ce que tu appelles une série de mythes, une série de préconceptions vis-à-vis de notamment l'image du Wallon
auprès des Flamands, la question des transferts interrégionaux, toute une série de, voilà, la question du chômage également, toute une série de choses que tu t'attelles à déconstruire.
Et face à ces mythes très ancrés dans l'inconscient, notamment flamand, c'est clairement ce que tu attaques dans le livre.
Face à ces mythes-là, tu choisis d'y aller vraiment à base de rationnel, de chiffres, de données. Il y a beaucoup de notes de bas de page, beaucoup de graphiques.
C'est une approche, oui, je le disais, approche solvéusienne. Est-ce que ça te va comme qualificatif ?
Je sais pas si je dirais solvésienne. Solvay, c'est donc une école de gestion bien connue ici à Bruxelles.
Mais en tout cas, il y a une volonté et je sais que c'est peut-être pas habituel pour des livres politiques, mais de me baser sur une réalité statistique et la réalité des faits.
Moi, j'en peux plus de vivre dans un monde où les politiques font des déclarations à l'emporte-pièce sans avoir aucun fondement chiffré.
Mais au-delà, et on parlera de la Wallonie et de la Flandre, ce que j'attaque aussi, c'est le mécanisme qui forme les clichés.
Moi, j'ai grandi à Charleroi, j'étais à l'école ici à Bruxelles, une université prestigieuse, une chouette école de commerce.
Quand je suis arrivé sur les bancs de l'école, les gars qui sortaient des bonnes écoles bruxelloises disaient : « Tiens, c'est marrant, à Charleroi, vous avez aussi appris à faire des intégrales ou des dérivées ».
Puis après, j'ai travaillé pour une entreprise internationale en dehors de la Belgique et on te regardait comme le petit Belge provincial par rapport aux Parisiens.
Puis j'ai été étudié aux États-Unis, dans une grande université. Et là, on me regardait en tant qu'Européen, venant du continent en déclin de la vieille Europe.
Donc ce que je veux dire aussi à travers ce livre, c'est de dire : on est toujours le compte de quelqu'un d'autre.
Et c'est quelque part aussi vieux que l'humanité et c'est un processus qui est très dangereux parce que dans les clichés, il y a quelque chose de vrai.
Il y a une réalité statistique. Est-ce que la Flandre est plus pauvre que la Wallonie ? Oui. Est-ce qu'il y a plus de chômage en Wallonie ?
L'inverse. La Wallonie est plus pauvre.
Oui oui, la Wallonie est plus pauvre que la Flandre, effectivement. Oui. Est-ce qu'il y a proportionnellement plus de personnes en situation de chômage en Wallonie qu'en Flandre ?
Certainement. Mais ce qui est intéressant dans le cliché, c'est que d'une réalité statistique objective, on la dérive sur une caractéristique personnelle de la population.
Donc, comme le chômage est plus élevé en Wallonie qu'en Flandre, donc les Wallons sont paresseux, veulent pas aller bosser et il faut leur taper un coup de pied sur les fesses.
Et ce type de raisonnement, c'est un raisonnement qui est à la base de toutes les dynamiques de rejet et de haine. Oui, aujourd'hui en Belgique, il y a une différence de taux d'emploi entre les gens d'origine immigrée
et, je dirais, j'aime pas l'appellation, mais les Belges depuis plusieurs générations sur le territoire ici en Belgique.
Est-ce que pour autant les personnes immigrées sont plus paresseuses ou ne veulent pas s'intégrer
? Bah non, parce qu'il y a toute une série de facteurs qui jouent parce que, et qui sont corrélés avec le niveau d'éducation, avec les quartiers dans lesquels ces personnes habitent, etc.
Et donc c'est vraiment ça le combat que j'essaie de mener à travers ce livre, c'est de dire :
il y a un processus qui est toujours le même et assez dangereux de créer des clichés, de tirer des généralités sur une population à partir de moyennes statistiques.
Et il faut pouvoir expliquer, même si c'est complexe, quels sont tous les facteurs qui jouent derrière.
Oui, c'est ce que tu fais à plusieurs reprises dans le livre, c'est ces moyennes statistiques, tu les déconstruis et tu montres qu'elles en cachent d'autres.
Voilà, un exemple que je pourrais citer là, c'est celui de la question du taux d'emploi qui reste stable dans le temps,
mais on se rend compte qu'il y a d'une part la désindustrialisation qui opère et qui continue à supprimer des emplois
et d'autre part, une création d'emplois qui est importante à côté et qui, du coup, montre un certain dynamisme et qui casse cette image, justement,
que renvoie le cliché initial
d'inertie et de—
Tout à fait. Et ça, c'est vraiment une histoire de, quand je suis rentré à Charleroi en 2017, il y avait eu toute une série de grandes fermetures.
La sidérurgie qui fermait des grands sites, mais c'est très compliqué pour des gens qui ne connaissent pas le territoire d'une ville industrielle de se rendre compte de l'ampleur de ce que c'est.
Quand une entreprise ferme dans une ville, c'est une catastrophe. Mais quand une ville a été construite autour de son usine, c'est l'identité même de la ville qui est affectée.
Et c'est le cas à Charleroi, c'est le cas à La Louvière. Ce sont des villes qui ont été structurées autour de l'industrie.
La Louvière, c'est une agrégation de quartiers autour d'usines. Charleroi, c'est une agrégation de différents quartiers autour de mines puis de grands ensembles sidérurgiques.
Et donc il y a eu une série de catastrophes dans le secteur du verre, dans le secteur de la sidérurgie, puis dans les constructions métalliques, Caterpillar étant le dernier en date.
Et les gens me disaient : On n'a pas— c'est difficile d'avoir de l'espoir. Parce que c'est vrai que quand on regarde les chiffres d'évolution de l'emploi, ce qu'on voyait, c'était—
Une flatline.
Flatline, exactement. La toute croissance était proche de zéro. Et donc ils disaient : Mais purée, ça augmente partout et nous, ça n'augmente pas.
Et c'est vrai qu'aussi, il y a une critique du discours politique qui dit : Oui, mais regardez, on crée des emplois, etc.
En fait, non, ça ne se voyait pas dans les chiffres. Donc j'ai dit : Mais tiens, il faut regarder de façon beaucoup plus profonde, il faut déconstruire ça.
Et ce qu'on voyait, c'est qu'en fait, la flatline, elle masquait un mouvement de destruction très important dans la vieille industrie, la sidérurgie, le verre, etc.
Et un mouvement de création très important dans des nouveaux secteurs, les biotechnologies, la manufacture de pointe, certains secteurs du digital, la logistique.
Et donc cette analyse, par exemple, ça, c'est l'exemple pour moi d'avoir une forme de précision analytique
permet non seulement d'avoir un impact psychologique, parce que d'un coup, les gens se rendaient compte de se dire : Ah, on perd des emplois, mais pas parce qu'on est nuls,
mais parce que partout, la sidérurgie a du mal en Europe occidentale, partout, les grandes industries de fabrication métallique ont du mal.
Mais par contre, le moteur de création, il s'est enclenché. Et ça, c'est le paradoxe de notre région, c'est notre identité, c'est qu'on est une région à la fois avec beaucoup de destruction d'emplois et beaucoup de création d'emplois.
Et ça va même plus loin, parce que nous, en tant que leader public, à travers un bête schéma analytique comme ça, on identifie aussi : OK, quelles sont les priorités pour l'action publique à Charleroi ?
C'est de se dire qu'en fait, les emplois qui sont détruits ne sont pas du tout les mêmes que les emplois qui sont créés parce qu'ils sont
nettement plus qualifiés, nécessitent des qualifications plus avancées et sont des emplois qui sont occupés par des gens qui n'habitent pas nécessairement la région.
Et donc, pour nous, nos enjeux à Charleroi, et c'est là-dessus qu'on travaille, c'est, un : travailler sur l'enseignement supérieur, faire en sorte que des
gamins et des gamines qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir des parents universitaires ou ce réflexe d'aller à l'université puissent avoir accès à l'enseignement supérieur.
Et le deuxième levier, c'est de faire en sorte de re-résidentialiser les travailleurs, que les gens qui viennent travailler à Charleroi se disent : Tiens, c'est non seulement chouette d'y travailler,
mais en plus, il y a toute une série de quartiers qui sont super beaux, je vous encourage à venir voir, avec des chouettes écoles et où je peux faire grandir ma famille.
Ce premier levier, c'est le levier de l'ascension sociale, finalement. Qu'est-ce que tu observes comme challenge à ce niveau-là ?
Qu'est-ce que, comme difficulté pour mettre en place cette ascension sociale ?
Je pense que l'accès à l'enseignement supérieur est un enjeu énorme. On a un système scolaire qui reste un des plus inégalitaires en Europe. Donc,
faire en sorte que les enfants des classes populaires, les enfants qui sont des familles en Belgique qui viennent d'arriver, puissent aller jusqu'au bout de leur scolarité secondaire en évitant le décrochage, en évitant la relégation,
c'est un premier défi qui est très important.
Et puis, on voit qu'il y a un problème d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur, que ce soit l'enseignement universitaire ou non universitaire.
Et ça, là aussi, il y a une question sociale qui se pose. C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, un cote, ça vous coûte quatre cents euros.
Et si vous devez, par exemple, si vous vous rendiez à Charleroi et que vous devez aller à l'uni, à l'ULB ou même à Mons ou à Namur, bah, vous perdez deux heures et demie par jour en train.
Et donc, vous ne partez pas sur la même ligne de départ qu'un gamin qui peut se payer un cote ou qui a grandi juste à côté de la, dans un chouette quartier, à côté d'une université.
Tu parles dans le livre aussi de ton regret du fait que l'UCL a été implantée dans le Béwé, donc au sein vraiment de ce triangle qui réunit Bruxelles, le Béwé, enfin tout ça.
Je parle un peu du Béwé parce que c'est intéressant. Le Béwé, c'est, enfin, c'est marrant comme on dit le Béwé, c'est devenu une évidence.
À chaque fois qu'on dit Béwé, on se dit : Est-ce que tout le monde va comprendre de quoi on parle ?
Non, le Brabant wallon, c'est une histoire intéressante. C'est une histoire intéressante. Parce que, un, ce qu'on ne sait pas, c'est que, en fait, ça montre tellement de choses, le Brabant wallon.
Un, c'est la preuve par l'absurde que la politique n'est pas responsable de tout. C'est-à-dire que le Brabant wallon, c'est la province la plus riche de Belgique.
Et donc moi, souvent, quand j'ai des contradicteurs flamands, souvent pas les plus intelligents, qui me disent : Ouais, mais vous, en Wallonie, avec votre politique complètement foireuse, vous êtes incapables de créer de la richesse.
Je leur dis : Mais regarde, par exemple, la politique wallonne, c'est la même à Wavre qu'à La Louvière ou à Flémalle ou dans le truc.
C'est un peu ce que tu disais juste avant, c'est une inégalité des différentes—
Donc si on était mauvais, on serait mauvais partout. Ça montre. Donc ça, ça montre déjà, un, le Brabant wallon. Deux, le Brabant wallon, ce que ça montre, c'est que la richesse est liée à d'autres choses.
La plus grande source de richesse du Brabant wallon, c'est le fait qu'il y a des externalités énormes de Bruxelles, des flux de navetteurs, etc.
Le patrimoine aussi.
Ouais, ça montre aussi un peu la difficulté de notre système et la difficulté pour Bruxelles. C'est-à-dire que Bruxelles est de loin le plus gros moteur de création de richesse en Belgique, mais n'en capte qu'une petite partie parce qu'il y a
plus de la moitié de la force du travail qui fait la navette pour y aller.
qui fait la navette pour y aller.
Et donc toi, tu plaides aussi pour une métropolisation de, par exemple, Charleroi, par exemple Liège, pour que justement, ce poumon économique qu'est Bruxelles laisse un peu de place à d'autres villes en Wallonie.
Je pense qu'on a une vision des flux en Belgique qui sont des flux nord-sud, comme si c'était la Flandre qui irriguait le territoire wallon, mais aussi Bruxelles.
En fait, la Flandre, comme la Belgique, comme beaucoup d'autres pays, les flux économiques,
ils sont du centre, Bruxelles et le Brabant, qui sont les deux provinces les plus riches, Bruxelles, qui est deux cent pour cent plus riche que la Flandre en PIB, pas en revenus, mais en PIB, vers la périphérie.
Et qu'aujourd'hui, par exemple, on parle beaucoup, dans—
je le mentionne dans le livre, des transferts via la Sécurité sociale, mais que si on calculait les transferts via les revenus, donc des gens qui génèrent un revenu quelque part et qui le dépensent ailleurs,
eh bien, on est sur un ordre de grandeur facteur dix par rapport aux flux de Sécurité sociale.
Donc les vrais flux,
ce sont les flux de Bruxelles vers la périphérie. Sur la métropolisation, je pense que c'est un axe de développement important pour la Wallonie parce qu'on a très peu d'exemples de régions dans le monde qui arrivent à se développer sans
métropole
forte parce qu'aujourd'hui en 2023,
l'économie, elle se structure dans des aires métropolitaines qui vont concentrer les talents, qui vont concentrer l'innovation, les centres de recherche, les gens qui ont du capital, les services aux entreprises, etc.
Et que la Wallonie, c'est une des faiblesses de son territoire. Elle est entourée de métropoles plus importantes qu'elle : Lille, Bruxelles, Luxembourg au sud, Aix-la-Chapelle à l'est.
Et donc y a un enjeu en Wallonie de travailler sur la remétropolisation autour d'un pôle naturel qui est Liège, autour d'un autre pôle qui serait la grande conurbation du Hainaut, Charleroi, La Louvière, etc.,
pour capter une partie de ces richesses qui est créée sur le territoire.
J'aimerais revenir sur le pitch initial, c'est-à-dire l'idée que face aux stéréotypes, aux clichés désinformés, tu veux présenter des données très factuelles et convaincre.
Quand on observe, par exemple, les publicités, hein, que tout le monde connaît vis-à-vis de ce cycliste flamand qui pédale très très fort pour tirer un Wallon un peu alcoolique qui a un peu de bide.
Cette publicité ne s'attaque pas,
n'arrive pas avec des arguments rationnels, des données objectives, etc.
Cette publicité attaque plutôt le champ du pathos, de l'émotionnel, du— il cherche à déclencher une réaction très vive et très forte et très énervée chez l'électeur flamand.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'on peut arriver à raisonner, à discuter, à calmer un tel électeur face à un discours qui part plutôt non pas sur le logos, sur la raison, mais sur l'émotionnel, le pathos ?
C'est une excellente question. C'est une excellente question parce que c'est vrai que
dans la rhétorique définie au sens classique, y a trois dimensions : le pathos, le logos, mais aussi l'éthos, donc la capacité à être en phase avec ce qu'on incarne.
Mon livre, effectivement, est un livre qui joue premièrement sur le logos. Je vise via une série d'arguments chiffrés, structurés, une partie sur l'éthos, c'est-à-dire que—
Tu parles beaucoup de Thomas Dermine.
J'essaie d'incarner. Je l'écris pas de nulle part. Je l'écris parce que moi-même, j'ai été confronté à ça.
Et quelque part, c'est un peu, voilà, un des objectifs, de façon très humble, que je me suis fixé dans ma vie, de travailler sur ces enjeux-là.
Est-ce que j'y arriverai ou pas ? On verra, mais de travailler sur ces enjeux, d'incarner un renouveau en Wallonie, c'est quelque chose qui m'anime énormément.
Et peu sur le pathos. Quelque chose qui m'a déçu énormément, c'est une interview qui est sortie ce matin dans le Trends où on pose la question à Bart De Wever : avez-vous lu le livre de Thomas Dermine ?
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Sa réponse : ce McKinsey boy, il est très malin. Son livre est très bien torché. On a envie d'y croire, mais je pense que lui-même n'y croit pas.
Donc vraiment, il a pas répondu sur le fond.
C'est une réponse de pathos. C'est-à-dire que, un, il déclasse son adversaire en disant : « Machin, il a travaillé pour une société internationale » comme si quelqu'un, parce qu'il a,
il a travaillé pour une société privée, ne peut pas être de gauche et partager un idéal de solidarité, de partage de revenus dans la société, etc.
Et deux, il dit : « Son livre est bien construit. C'est quelqu'un de malin, donc lui-même ne doit même pas y croire.
» Donc c'est un argument, enfin— et c'est ma frustration parfois en politique, mais qu'il faut accepter parce que de tout temps, de tout âge, les grandes conquêtes,
y compris les conquêtes de la gauche, ont été construites avec un mélange
d'une lecture analytique sans scrupule de la réalité, mais basée sur des faits, mais aussi une capacité de dirigeants, de leaders politiques, syndicaux, à jouer sur ce qui fait bouger l'humain et c'est aussi l'émotion.
Après, je pense que tout part quand même d'un travail analytique. Je veux dire, le livre qui a peut-être le plus influencé
l'histoire politique contemporaine, le Capital de Marx, a été écrit par Marx à une époque où il y avait moins de 10 % de la population qui était lettrée.
Donc, on doit aussi ce livre-là, effectivement, je l'écris, peut-être pas le tout tout grand public, même si honnêtement, ça se lit, ça se lit assez, de façon assez fluide.
C'est accessible.
Mais c'est assez accessible. J'ai aucune prétention scientifique ou que ce soit avec le livre.
Mais c'est vrai que ça s'adresse à un certain public, mais je pense que c'est toujours en travaillant sur les différents aspects qu'il faut y aller.
Ça amène à un autre sujet connexe qui est, donc, et je sais que le politicien n'aime pas commenter les sondages, mais on est quand même dans une situation où on
sent un petit peu dans l'air que les partis qui sont le Vlaams Belang et le PTB, qui jouent donc exclusivement ou très majoritairement sur le pathos,
ça se discute, font, on le voit en poupe et sont en bonne position, en tout cas dans les sondages.
Là aussi se pose la question de pathos versus logos.
Tu as 100 % raison. Moi, je suis vraiment troublé par ça. Et j'en discutais avec des collègues flamands
de partis progressistes qui disent : en fait, je vais faire une comparaison historique qui est pas simple, mais dans les années 30,
quand on voyait l'émergence du fascisme dans plusieurs pays, c'était quelque part soutenu par
une grogne populaire sur base de données socioéconomiques qui justifiaient la grogne.
Si on regarde l'Allemagne sous la République de Weimar,
on voit la montée du national-socialisme parce que y a tout un ressenti par rapport aux conséquences du traité de Versailles qui assoiffent l'Allemagne, parce que y a un taux de chômage qui atteint presque 30 %.
Aujourd'hui, en Flandre, aux Pays-Bas, y a jamais eu aussi peu de chômage. Ils ont jamais été aussi riches. Y a jamais eu aussi peu de criminalité.
Y a jamais eu autant de besoins d'étrangers pour faire tourner l'économie. Et malgré ça—
La grogne vient plutôt alors de ce qu'on appelle les guerres culturelles, donc les anti-woke, les on ne peut plus rien dire, etc.
Oui, mais qui sont fictifs. Parce qu'en fait, aujourd'hui, sur base de tous les critères économiques, c'est ça qui est marrant, c'est qu'en Flandre, ils ont un besoin criant de main-d'œuvre,
un besoin criant d'immigration, parce que le premier frein à leur croissance et à leur prospérité future, c'est des facteurs liés au capital humain et à l'importation de main-d'œuvre.
Et donc c'est ça qui est intéressant, c'est qu'on est effectivement dans une forme de démocratie où le ressenti, où le pathos domine. Moi, un de mes artistes contemporains préférés, c'est Orelsan.
Mais il y a ça dans ses chansons quoi, l'odeur de l'essence, tout le monde critique, personne ne cherche à se comprendre, tout est binaire. Et on—
voilà, une opposition, un clash de style permanent. Et c'est vrai que pour exister dans la politique actuelle,
pour émerger sur les réseaux sociaux, pour être entendu, parce que les réseaux sociaux sont en fait les caisses de résonance qui permettent après aux politiques d'être invités sur les plateaux,
il faut cliver, il faut amener, pas de la nuance et c'est des jeux dangereux.
Ce que disait
Raoul Hedebouw dans une interview pour Le Vent se lève en Flandre, donc, en France,
qui est donc plutôt un journal bien à l'extrême gauche, c'est que le rôle des députés PTB au sein de la Chambre des représentants n'était pas tellement d'agir au niveau des changements systémiques, de légiférer, etc.
Mais plutôt d'utiliser le Parlement comme un piédestal pour faire des vidéos Facebook en fait, pour agir—
Mais pour moi, c'est un dévoiement du fonctionnement de la démocratie. Et Raoul Hedebouw a eu cette critique-là de la part de leaders syndicaux.
Des leaders syndicaux ont rappelé plusieurs fois à des députés du PTB de dire : le contre-pouvoir,
c'est nous. Un parti politique, par essence, quand il participe aux urnes, il a envie de s'engager dans la transformation du réel, dans le rapport de force d'un gouvernement.
Aujourd'hui, pour moi, je l'ai dit sur antenne, le PTB, c'est plus une assoc en fait, ou un syndicat ou un organe militant avec lesquels, honnêtement, en tant que socialiste, je partage certaines valeurs, je partage certains combats.
Mais aujourd'hui, par rapport à la nécessité de changer le rapport de force
dans les gouvernements, de traduire une revendication en texte de loi et puis qui va produire des effets sur la vie réelle,
en fait, il déforce fortement la gauche, puisque les voix qu'il capte sont des voix de contestation et ne sont pas des voix qui vont contribuer à construire le monde.
Et au-delà de ça, je dis, je partage toute une série de sujets avec le PTB. Il y a des éléments qui nous différencient fondamentalement, notamment en matière internationale.
Vous n'entendrez jamais le PTB critiquer Poutine trop fort. Toutes les difficultés que ça a été pour condamner l'invasion en Ukraine.
C'est un parti qui a ses ambiguïtés avec certains régimes. Et voilà.
Ce qu'il explique aussi dans l'interview, c'est que pour être en mesure de vraiment comprendre le marxisme, la société, vraiment entamer un changement, il fallait
quinze ans de formation vraiment marxiste et que le pouvoir décisionnel devait être
dans les mains d'une poignée de gens qui ont vraiment bien—
C'est un autre aspect très complexe avec le PTB. Et je ne dis pas que nos organes de gouvernance interne sont parfaits, mais il y a une,
une tendance effectivement à une opacité du pouvoir qui d'ailleurs, en fait, génère le fait que beaucoup de députés ou de conseillers communaux décrochent.
Je veux dire, par exemple, la commune que je connais le mieux à Charleroi, ben il y a eu chaque année un ou deux députés, enfin mandataires communaux,
PTB qui se désengagent ou qui critiquent certains aspects de fonctionnement interne, de manque de transparence.
Je ne dis pas que c'est parfait dans les autres partis, mais en tout cas, il y a une volonté de transparence en tout cas.
Pour revenir sur le livre maintenant et donc les fameux mythes qui sont dans l'esprit, notamment des Flamands vis-à-vis des Wallons, il y a, voilà, toute une série de facteurs circonstanciels, hein, la situation économique, la
désindustrialisation, le fait que la Flandre a un port.
Et tu expliques tout ça très bien dans le livre. À quel moment est-ce que ces facteurs, donc, qui sont circonstanciels, laissent place à un certain nationalisme, au mythe du Wallon paresseux ?
Parce que, voilà, par exemple, quand au début des années 60, le chômage était supérieur, plus élevé en Flandre, il me semble, il me semble pas qu'il y avait cette image du Flamand paresseux ou ce genre de choses.
Il y a eu très longtemps l'image du Flamand paresseux.
Ah ok, autant pour moi.
Ouais, tout à fait, mais plus au 19e siècle. Mais par exemple, il y a des expressions dans le patois wallon qui traduisent toujours ça.
Moi, avec mes potes, quand on dit,
quand quelqu'un a fait un truc de travers, on dit : gros Flamand va. En fait, c'est une expression qui,
en wallon ou sale Flamand, qui date en fait de la génération de nos grands-parents, parce que les Flamands qui venaient travailler en Wallonie étaient perçus comme
peu dégourdis, peu motivés, etc.
Donc, il y a eu des inversions. C'est ça que je trouvais hyper intéressant,
ce clin d'œil historique, c'est qu'à l'échelle, finalement, d'un siècle,
le problème, c'est qu'en tant que citoyen, on a envie de mesurer le changement et en particulier maintenant, avec l'immédiateté que nous procurent les technologies digitales, etc.
On a envie de mesurer le changement à l'échelle de quelques trimestres ou quelques années. Mais non, le changement économique, c'est le résultat de cycles longs qui peuvent difficilement même s'appréhender à l'échelle d'une vie.
Parce que c'est vrai que sur l'histoire de la Belgique, pays très récent, 200 ans, en fait, il y a eu deux tiers de l'histoire du pays où la Wallonie a été plus riche.
Juste quand tu remets ça en perspective, tu te dis : ah ouais, c'est intéressant. Il y a eu toute une partie de l'histoire et je pense que ça peut s'inverser. Ça s'inversera pas,
honnêtement, en cinq ans et en dix ans. Et là aussi, il faut le dire avec des chiffres. C'est-à-dire que si on veut, et je le dis dans le livre, si on veut que la Wallonie rattrape le niveau de prospérité
de la Flandre, il faudrait un différentiel de croissance entre les deux régions de l'ordre de grandeur de 1,5 % pendant 20 ans.
Dans un monde qui croît à 1 % et je ne suis pas nécessairement sûr qu'il doit croître beaucoup plus vite pour des questions d'un autre ordre, d'ordre environnemental, c'est complètement irréaliste.
Donc c'est ça la question compliquée, c'est de se dire : des facteurs, comme tu appelles circonstanciels, expliquent une partie, l'histoire, la localisation.
Entre guillemets, c'est facile pour une commune comme Grez-Doiceau ou comme Lasne, d'être plus riche qu'une commune comme
Marcinelle ou de la périphérie de Charleroi, parce que vous avez, sans rien faire, un flux de richesse très important qui arrive.
Mais par contre, il ne faut pas se résoudre au déterminisme des facteurs circonstanciels. Il ne faut pas se dire : en fait, tout est foutu, tout est joué d'avance, tout est perdu d'avance.
C'est une autre chanson d'Orelsan. Désolé, c'est le thème de la soirée. Parce que sinon, moi, je me serais jamais engagé en politique.
Si je me suis engagé en politique, c'est aussi parce que je pensais qu'on peut améliorer le réel, mais on doit améliorer le réel en se rendant compte d'où on part et où on va.
Et je dis exactement la même chose à la Flandre. Je dis à la Flandre : « Vous n'avez aucune grandeur à vous comparer à la Wallonie ».
C'est comme si tu compares un joueur de tennis qui est unijambiste et qui a des difficultés physiques importantes avec une superstar.
Y a aucune grandeur à se comparer à une économie qui n'a absolument rien de comparable, d'un point de vue historique, d'un point de vue de la localisation.
Si vous voulez vraiment faire les grands, comparez-vous à Rotterdam,
comparez-vous à la région de Rotterdam, comparez-vous à la Hanse de Hambourg, comparez-vous à des régions qui ont la même histoire que vous, qui ont émergé comme des carrefours
commerciaux et intellectuels au Moyen Âge et qui occupent des grands ports aujourd'hui.
Et là, en fait, ce qu'on voit, c'est que la Flandre n'est pas plus développée, ni plus riche, ni qu'elle redistribue plus que Rotterdam ne distribue au reste des Pays-Bas.
Mmm-hmm. C'est aller vers la facilité, quelque part.
C'est aller vers la facilité et c'est quelque part le génie de la droite nationaliste flamande et singulièrement incarnée par Bart De Wever depuis une vingtaine d'années, c'est d'avoir traduit une revendication flamande qui était en fait,
jusque dans les années 80, 90, essentiellement une revendication linguistique et culturelle.
Parce que effectivement, et je pense, pour partie légitime, d'une forme de domination francophone sur la population flamande et qui derrière aussi masque des questions de classe.
C'est-à-dire que c'était aussi la bourgeoisie francophone, d'ailleurs, qui était en fait pas wallonne, mais qui était localisée dans les villes flamandes et à Bruxelles.
Et donc il y a ce ressenti-là qui est exprimé à travers le mouvement flamand.
Et lui, il a traduit ça dans une revendication économique de, en utilisant les clichés, on se rappelle, de Bart De Wever qui transporte des billets de cash à Stripenbach, etc.
Et c'est ça son génie. Il a transformé une revendication culturelle et linguistique en une revendication économique. Mais à la base, les Flamands du mouvement flamand, ils en veulent pas du tout aux Wallons.
Ils en veulent à la bourgeoisie qui se fait, euh, les domine aussi linguistiquement parce qu'elle est francophone.
Donc, il y a un ressentiment envers la bourgeoisie qui s'est dévié vers les—
Un ressentiment contre les Wallons et de, ces gens nous privent d'une forme de bien-être ou nous bloquent dans notre élan parce qu'on leur transfère des montants incroyables, etc.
Et dans le livre, en fait, ce qui est intéressant, c'est que c'est pas un— Je ne crée pas de nouvelles recherches. J'agrège toute une série d'éléments, de lecture, d'études économiques que je lis, etc.
Et je reprends, par exemple, une étude qui est sortie dans l'anonymat le plus complet de la Banque nationale, mais qui montre que sur cette question précise des transferts, quand j'ai lu ça, j'ai dû relire trois fois le paragraphe,
la Belgique est le pays en Europe, après l'Autriche,
où il y a le moins de transferts entre ces régions.
Donc, les Flamands adorent regarder la Hollande en disant : « Regardez ce qui se passe là-bas, c'est super, etc. » Mais en fait, la région de Rotterdam,
elle redistribue beaucoup plus à la Frise, au nord des Pays-Bas, que ce que fait la Flandre par rapport à la Wallonie.
En France, même si vous excluez Paris, parce que Paris est une concentration extrême de richesse à Paris en France, mais même si vous regardez, par exemple, ce que Bordeaux transfère à des régions voisines,
un peu plus isolées, si vous regardez ce que Lyon transfère à la Lorraine, vous avez des montants de transfert qui sont beaucoup, beaucoup plus importants.
Et donc, la Belgique, il y a absolument rien d'extraordinaire dans nos transferts. Oui, il y a des flux de transfert. Oui, il faut essayer de se battre avec des convergences économiques pour les faire diminuer, mais c'est absolument pas exceptionnel.
Mmm-hmm. Dans le livre, tu reprends également les courbes du PIB pour chaque région et tu expliques que le fossé entre le PIB au niveau de la Flandre et celui au niveau de la Wallonie
a cessé de se creuser dès le moment où on a régionalisé
les compétences économiques et industrielles.
Dans la couverture média à ton sujet, souvent, tu es décrit implicitement ou c'est pas— Il y a une part de doute, mais tu es décrit comme quelqu'un de plutôt régionaliste.
Est-ce que tu rejoins ce qualificatif ?
Il y a plusieurs choses à ta question. Effectivement, il y a un point de croisement dans les années 60 où la Flandre devient plus riche que la Wallonie en richesse par habitant.
Un écart qui se creuse de façon vertigineuse entre 60 et milieu des années 90. C'est vraiment le pic du déclin industriel wallon,
là où la Flandre arrive à se positionner très très bien dans les années 60, 70, 80, dans la nouvelle mondialisation, l'ouverture au monde.
Bah notamment grâce à ses ports.
Depuis 20 ans, ce qu'on observe, c'est que cet écart est et reste important. 27 % d'écart de PIB, c'est beaucoup, mais que contrairement à une certaine lecture de : attention, l'écart explose, en fait, il reste stable.
Il reste stable à hauteur de 27 %, et que la convergence, moi, je pense, on doit— La prochaine phase, c'est une phase de convergence qui va être très, très lente.
Comme je le disais, il faudra probablement plusieurs décennies avant d'avoir une convergence complète, mais ça doit rester un objectif.
Est-ce que je suis décrit comme un régionaliste ? Peut-être, mais certainement pas un régionaliste romantique ou certainement pas un régionaliste en symétrie au régionaliste flamand.
C'est-à-dire que si je devais être régionaliste, je serais un régionaliste pragmatique. C'est-à-dire que je pense que, un, on n'ira jamais vers un retour en arrière, vers une refédéralisation de certaines compétences.
Peut-être, mais de façon très très marginale. Pourquoi ? Parce que vous avez aujourd'hui 60 % de l'électorat flamand qui est radicalement opposé.
Donc à un moment, en politique, on peut rêver—
Mmm-hmm.
Mais il y a quand même un principe de réalité politique qui, en tout cas, à court terme, je pense pas que ce soit possible.
Là, tu n'exprimes pas tellement tes convictions, tu fais juste le constat de la situation flamande.
Par contre, je pense que sur une série de matières qui sont essentielles au développement économique, eh bien aujourd'hui, on a une construction institutionnelle dans l'espace francophone qui est trop complexe.
Par exemple, je pense qu'il y a un lien très très fort entre la culture et le développement économique.
Je pense que recréer une forme d'ethos commun, d'envie commune de travailler pour sa région, de s'y impliquer, de se battre pour créer de l'emploi, pour que les entrepreneurs restent dans la région, etc.
Tu plaides pour une identité régionale plus forte.
Ça passe par des leviers culturels. Or, aujourd'hui, il y a peu de leviers culturels au niveau de la région.
Ils sont au niveau, voilà, ils sont au niveau de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles qui est en déficit.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui, tout ce qui est interaction entre le monde du travail et l'enseignement, c'est beaucoup trop complexe.
Mmm-hmm.
Je pense que ce n'est pas normal dans une région où on a des ratés dans l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes que le ministre de l'Enseignement ne soit pas assis chaque semaine à côté du ministre de l'Économie.
Et donc oui, là aussi, je plaiderais pour une simplification en ayant par exemple le système d'alternance en Belgique francophone, il est exercé en partie par la région, en partie par la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Donc je ne suis pas régionaliste pour le plaisir de dire : « Je trouve que la Wallonie, c'est super et j'ai un amour émotionnel pour la Wallonie ».
Je suis régionaliste sur certaines dimensions parce que je pense que pour offrir le maximum de possibilités d'émancipation à nos jeunes et à notre région,
eh bien, il y a certains leviers qui seraient mieux exercés de façon plus efficace au niveau des régions.
C'est juste ça, mon rapport à la Wallonie. Et pour le reste, je n'ai absolument pas cette idée d'identité exclusive. Moi, je suis
super fier de, tu vois, d'être supporter du Sporting de Charleroi, tribune, etc. Donc je suis, tu vois, très carolo, mais presque au sens folklorique du terme, parce que c'est prè— mais je suis aussi
profondément attaché à mon territoire qui est un territoire qui a une histoire industrielle particulière et pour lequel, en tout cas, j'ai estimé que ça valait la peine de se battre.
Mais je suis aussi fondamentalement super heureux d'être Belge. Je trouve qu'on a une super culture et je trouve que le fait d'être un pays multilingue
avec Bruxelles qui est une des villes les plus internationales au monde, c'est une richesse incroyable.
Et en étant aussi profondément pro-européen, parce que les plus grands leviers du réchauffement climatique, de la planification fiscale doivent être construits à ce niveau-là.
Et nos niveaux d'identité, ils s'enrichissent mutuellement. Et en ça, ça diffère fondamentalement d'une forme de nationalisme qui peut exister en Flandre où une identité exclut les autres.
C'est-à-dire que si je suis Flamand, je ne suis pas Belge. Moi, je suis Wallon et je suis très fier d'être Belge et très heureux.
Là où le bât blesse, c'est peut-être avec la situation pendant l'été 2020 où une coalition a été proposée entre PS et N-VA qui, pour résumer ça comme ça,
donnait beaucoup de leviers sociaux à la Wallonie et exigeait aussi toute une série de restructurations au niveau institutionnel.
Bah si je peux me permettre, c'est, 'fin, les éléments que vous avancez sont pas corrects. J'étais à l'époque—
C'est comme ça que c'était repris en tout cas.
Oui, oui, je sais que c'est le— 'fin la politique, c'est le jeu quoi. Donc certains ont intérêt à reprendre ce narratif-là.
Mais je peux vous jurer que c'est moi qui tenais la plume pour—
Oui, si tu y étais, oui.
...pour Paul Magnette dans les discussions avec Bart De Wever, parce que j'étais à l'époque chef de cabinet de Paul Magnette.
Bon, un, on n'était pas au tiers du quart d'un accord. Deux, cet accord ne contenait absolument pas les éléments que tu mentionnes pour la bonne et simple raison qu'il y avait aucun article de la Constitution qui était ouvert à révision.
Donc les éléments que tu mentionnes de régionalisation de la justice, etc. Même si on le voulait, c'était impossible à faire.
Il voulait, par exemple, des trucs du style suppression du 21 juillet et—
Oui, il voulait, la seule chose—
On bouge au 11 juillet.
Exactement. Les seules choses que la N-VA voulait et pouvait faire dans le frame institutionnel de l'époque, c'était de toucher à des symboles.
Donc, il y avait des questions de : je ne jure plus devant la Constitution, c'est la fête flamande et plus le 21 juillet qui est férié, dans l'ordre protocolaire.
Des trucs, des détails, parce que le nationalisme se nourrit aussi de ce genre de détails et de préséances, etc.
On est dans le pathos, de nouveau.
On est de nouveau sur le, oui, la puissance symbolique est très forte pour faire bouger les groupes humains.
Donc ce n'est pas avéré du tout.
Ce n'est pas avéré. Par contre, on a bien fait d'avoir cette phase de discussion parce que c'était impossible de former le gouvernement Vivaldi si on ne faisait pas la preuve matérielle que c'était impossible de faire avec la N-VA.
Et donc c'était une espèce de passage obligé où on a dû, et croyez-moi, c'était plutôt plus un supplice chinois qu'une balade de santé, passer plus d'un mois, cinq semaines, je pense, à l'époque, à discuter avec la N-VA.
Oui.
Et quelque part, la N-VA, encore une fois, je veux dire, la N-VA est un parti démocratique. Parfois, en Belgique francophone, on a l'impression que la N-VA, il y a une diabolisation de la N-VA.
Moi, je pense que, enfin, d'un point de vue de mes convictions personnelles, tout m'oppose à la N-VA, à ce qu'elle défend en matière migratoire, en matière socio-économique.
Mais la N-VA et Bart De Wever sont des démocrates, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne sont pas racistes, ils respectent la liberté de parole, ils s'engagent dans le débat démocratique.
Et donc, si c'est le plus grand partenaire en Flandre, il faut aussi les respecter en tant que tel.
Oui, c'est effectivement comme ça qu'ils sont perçus en Flandre. C'est le parti du gouvernement, le parti du sérieux, le parti, la stabilité, finalement.
Donc dans le livre, il est également question de la question du
capital privé. Donc c'est la question des holdings financiers qui n'ont apparemment pas cherché activement à financer la reconversion de la Wallonie,
plutôt privilégié des opportunités d'investissement dans d'autres territoires, notamment en Flandre et à l'étranger.
Donc, tu expliques qu'il y a un manque d'ancrage capitalistique en Wallonie qui a joué aussi dans les difficultés de développement ?
Oui, en fait, la Wallonie a une histoire très particulière parce qu'en fait, la Wallonie, hormis quelques villes qui ont émergé au Moyen Âge,
certaines de manière illustre et prononcée comme Liège, d'autres plus des villes avec une portée provinciale ou régionale comme,
comme Mons ou Tournai ou Namur.
La Wallonie était une région, en fait, essentiellement rurale et qui s'est peuplée au moment de la révolution industrielle.
Et donc, il y a toute une série d'infrastructures sociales, d'infrastructures culturelles qui n'ont pas été construites.
Par exemple, ça explique que dans le Hainaut, il n'y avait pas d'université jusque très récemment. L'université de Mons est assez récente, au-delà de quelques facultés.
Ça explique aussi qu'il n'y avait pas de bourgeoisie industrielle.
Le capital qui a permis de développer la sidérurgie, la grande industrie à Charleroi et dans le Hainaut, était du capital dans des holdings bruxelloises et donc, par essence, beaucoup plus mobile.
Et donc quand il y a eu le changement de cycle économique, le changement de cycle technologique, c'est du capital qui s'est réalloué sur d'autres géographies parce qu'il y avait plus d'opportunités d'investissement.
Ce qui est fondamentalement différent d'autres régions. Si vous regardez, par exemple, la vallée de la Ruhr, il y avait du capital, ce qu'on appelle du capital endogène, donc des grandes familles industrielles.
On connaît les groupes Thyssen, Krupp, etc.
Ce sont les personnes qui exploitaient des mines, puis ils ont fait de l'acier, puis ils ont fait des canons et aujourd'hui, ils sont toujours dans la région et ils font des ascenseurs, des produits pharmaceutiques, etc.
Parce que quelque part, le—
L'industrie s'est transformée, mais le capital est resté local.
Ce qui n'existe pas en Wallonie et certainement pas dans le Hainaut, parce qu'en fait, c'est une région où il n'y avait pas de bourgeoisie,
il n'y avait pas de détenteurs de capital qui exploitaient des entreprises depuis des générations, puisque tout le monde est arrivé au même moment, aux alentours du milieu du XIXᵉ siècle.
Et est-ce qu'il y a l'opportunité de faire apparaître ce capital ou bien est-ce que ça risque d'être compliqué ?
Non, c'est lent. Ça se déploie, mais c'est toujours la question. C'est aussi pour ça que le secteur public a dû prendre un rôle très fort, y compris dans la structuration de l'espace économique.
Et c'est pour ça que vous avez
aujourd'hui, par exemple, des holdings publics privés qui sont actifs. Parce que voilà, moi, je le vois avec des dossiers de start-up
à Charleroi ou en Wallonie, il y a très peu de groupes de venture capital parce qu'il y a très peu de familles qui sont établies, qui ont leurs fonds basés là-bas.
Et donc le risque, c'est sinon de les— et c'est très bien. Moi, je pense qu'il faut aussi, en tant qu'entrepreneur, partir loin, se développer, etc.
Mais le risque, c'est que certains soient freinés dans leur croissance par cette absence de capital endogène.
J'ai pas réagi tout à fait sur la question tout à l'heure de la fierté wallonne. Deux questions par rapport à ça. Qu'est-ce qui explique, selon toi, le fait qu'il y a une fierté de l'identité wallonne bien moindre par rapport à la Flandre ?
Et en quoi est-ce que c'est important de la faire apparaître ?
Bon, plusieurs raisons. La première raison, c'est que quand vous prenez des claques tout le temps, ce qui est le cas en Wallonie.
Il faut bien comprendre, la Wallonie, c'est trois millions et demi d'habitants, mais c'est deux point huit sur la province de Liège et le Hainaut.
Vraiment. En fait, quand on parle de la Wallonie, quatre-vingt pour cent de la population, c'est des provinces anciennement industrielles qui ont vécu un processus, nous, on est un peu trop jeunes pour ça, donc on ne s'en rend pas compte, mais
d'une violence absolument extrême dans cette phase de désindustrialisation.
Il faut imaginer, pour se rendre compte, par exemple, l'industrie wallonne, elle perd l'équivalent de dix fermetures d'une usine comme Caterpillar par an pendant vingt ans.
Donc c'est des dizaines de milliers de travailleurs qui
Et donc c'est difficile de développer une forme de fierté. Et même si rationnellement, votre logos vous dit : mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on est mauvais, c'est parce que les mines, elles ferment partout, parce qu'on passe au charbon et au gaz, etc.
C'est difficile. Et c'est pour ça aussi que vous allez retrouver ce qui fait le charme. Moi, c'est ce que j— en Wallonie, une forme de second degré permanent,
de on se prend pas vraiment au sérieux, mais aussi parfois, à l'excès, une culture du défaitisme qui fait qu'on n'ose pas
se retrousser les manches, avoir l'amour des choses bien faites, etc.
C'est un peu perdu d'avance. Il y a quelque chose comme ça.
Une identité en creux, un petit peu de—
Ouais, une identité un peu de, ouais, du second degré, d'humilité.
Un peu à l'excès quoi.
Un peu à l'excès. Ce qui est très bien, parce qu'il faut toujours mieux être trop humble que trop déconnecté, je pense, dans la vie.
Deuxièmement, il y a depuis vingt ans ce narratif flamand de : vous êtes nuls, vous êtes dépendants de nous, vous êtes fainéants, ça n'ira jamais.
Qui est en partie basé sur des réalités objectives, mais qui aussi déforme ou crée des attributs physiques de la population sur base de réalités statistiques.
Donc, ce n'est pas facile pour vous de vous sentir bien dans vos baskets quand vous avez votre voisin qui, lui, est la plus belle de la classe, qui vous dit en permanence : vous êtes moches et vous êtes nuls.
Il y a de ça, puis il y a le côté de levier institutionnel. L'identité, pour partie, elle est façonnée. Et la Flandre est un excellent exemple de ça.
C'est-à-dire qu'elle peut être construite, l'identité. Mais en Wallonie, vu l'absence de levier sur la culture, cette construction est néante.
Et il y a peut-être un dernier facteur qui est que je pense que la gauche, de façon générale, qui est dominante politiquement, a parfois trop peur d'utiliser ce levier relatif à l'identité.
Parce que, et effectivement, moi le premier, je trouve que—
On ressent un petit peu cette ambiguïté.
On peut jouer sur un danger de l'ambiguï— de l'identité. Tout le mouvement identitaire qu'on voit en Flandre, etc., qui nourrit l'extrême droite au final ou le rejet de l'autre, fait peur.
Mais l'identité peut être un vecteur fabuleux de développement économique et d'ethos inclusif. Par exemple, il y a quelque temps, la Flandre a travaillé sur son canon flamand, le Canon van Vlaanderen.
Moi, ça me faisait très peur. Je me dis : mais pourquoi travailler sur l'identité, etc. ? J'ai lu le document, c'est extrêmement bien fait.
C'est une mise en avant de certains militants dans la cause féministe. C'est des grands leaders syndicaux, c'est des grands scientifiques pour quelque part créer une conscience commune.
Je pense que parfois, c'est ce qui manque en Wallonie. Et c'est une idée que je lance peut-être en l'air, mais je pense que de travailler sur un équivalent qui serait
le canon de la Wallonie, de quelque part faire prendre conscience aux enfants qui naissent en Wallonie qu'on est une région qui a une grande histoire,
mais qui a aussi un grand présent, qu'aujourd'hui, on développe toujours des vaccins en Wallonie, les trains du futur, les fusées les plus performantes au monde sont faites dans nos usines.
Et ça, il faut pouvoir le raconter, qu'on a toujours des combattants pour l'égalité sur différents mouvements sociaux en pointe qui sont en Wallonie.
Et il y a ce travail de mise en avant qui doit être fait parce que reprendre confiance en soi, c'est un prérequis nécessaire au développement économique.
Tu clôtures le livre en expliquant donc qu'il faut se poser une série d'objectifs réalisables, réalistes. Donc parler de la croissance, non pas
un taux absolument monstrueux, mais voilà, un taux stable dans le temps et positif qui permettra, tu le disais, sur plusieurs décennies,
peut-être rejoindre celui de la Flandre, idéalement.
Et donc, tu parles notamment de la question du Green Deal européen et saisir les enjeux écologiques comme opportunité économique.
Est-ce que ça rejoint le fameux écosocialisme de Paul Magnette ?
Oui, c'est proche. C'est une application de concepts assez proches qui sont développés par Paul Magnette. Je pense que le destin de la Wallonie, il est intimement lié à celui des cycles économiques.
La Wallonie est une région qui a été créée par une transition énergétique, d'une société agraire vers une société dominée par le charbon.
Et la Wallonie a connu un déclin des suites d'une transition énergétique, avec un paradigme où l'énergie dominante était le charbon vers le pétrole et le gaz.
Et une des raisons pour lesquelles je suis optimiste, c'est que je pense que le prochain
cycle énergétique est porteur de nombreuses opportunités pour la Wallonie, que ce soit dans la réindustrialisation de certains secteurs industriels qui ont fait la richesse par le passé.
Aujourd'hui, en Wallonie, on réouvre des lignes qui produisent du verre, on réouvre des usines qui font des produits de base qui n'existaient pas,
mais aussi parce qu'il y a toute une série de secteurs
Que ce soit la construction, que ce soit le tourisme, il y a toute une série qui sont liés à la transition et qui ont un potentiel de développement économique important et un potentiel de création d'emplois important
aussi pour les jeunes peu qualifiés.
Mmm-hmm. Tu évoques également la question des fameux chômeurs de longue durée, hein, qui sont régulièrement la cible des attaques, par exemple, du Mouvement réformateur.
Donc ça, effectivement, tu confirmes dans tes stats, hein, que c'est plus présent en Wallonie que dans les autres régions.
Quelle est la stratégie à ce moment-là pour résoudre cette question ?
Ben, comme tu dis, moi, ce livre n'élude aucune question.
Mmm-hmm.
Et il y a des enjeux énormes sur le marché de l'emploi en Wallonie. Et effectivement, les chômeurs, ils sont environ deux cent mille.
Il y en a un sur deux qui est au chômage depuis plus de deux ans, donc qui a perdu quelque part une forme d'habitus lié au marché du travail, un sur deux qui a pas le diplôme du CESS, donc qui a quitté avant la rhéto,
et un sur deux qui n'a pas le permis de conduire.
Et certains qui cumulent plusieurs—
Mmm-hmm. Logiquement, oui, puisque un sur deux.
Parce que je vous voyais perplexe, je me suis dit.
Mais donc cette— il faut tenir compte de ça et que ce n'est pas parce qu'on a des offres d'emploi qui sont disponibles dans certains secteurs qu'on peut faire un matching one to one avec un demandeur d'emploi.
Et que même dans des emplois qui sont a priori peu qualifiés, par exemple, j'avais un exemple de aide-soignante.
Nonante pour cent des offres d'emploi d'aide-soignante en Wallonie, elles demandent d'avoir un véhicule. Quatre-vingt pour cent des aides ménagères demandent un véhicule aussi.
Donc là, vous avez des questions de, or avoir un véhicule, ça nécessite d'avoir quelques mois d'épargne pour pouvoir prendre un prêt ou je ne sais pas quoi.
Donc c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça n'en a l'air. Deuxièmement, et ça, c'est en tant qu'économiste que je me pose la question, aujourd'hui, il y a deux cent mille chômeurs en Belgique,
il y a cinq cent mi— et ils ont plutôt tendance à diminuer.
Il y a cinq cent mille malades de longue durée et ils ont tendance à exploser. Et donc, ce que je trouve toujours intéressant, c'est que le débat médiatique est inversement proportionnel à l'ampleur du défi.
Aujourd'hui, le défi, en fait, de l'activité,
c'est plus d'endiguer l'épidémie de maladies
professionnelles, notamment avec des maladies musculo-squelettiques dans certains métiers, des maladies psychologiques, enfin, de type burn out ou bore out ou autres,
ou déprime, dépression dans d'autres métiers qui sont plus des métiers de bureau.
Et ça, c'est des enjeux beaucoup plus importants. Comment on redéfinit le sens du travail ? Comment on fait pour adapter le temps de travail pour les personnes âgées, pour
les mamans ou les papas qui veulent ralentir au moment où ils ont des enfants ?
Ça, c'est les vrais leviers pour augmenter le taux d'emploi en Wallonie,
qui doivent être faits en parallèle des chômeurs, mais de travailler sur vraiment des mécanismes d'accompagnement et de rapprochement du marché du travail des chômeurs de longue durée.
Mais aujourd'hui, on parle tout le temps de taper sur les plus faibles et très peu de comment on fait pour endiguer cette épidémie de malades de longue durée.
Oui, donc c'est la fameuse notion de chômage dégressif que plaident beaucoup les libéraux.
Qui, by the way, ne marche pas. Je veux dire, toutes les études académiques montrent que ça ne marche pas. Et c'est pas parce que vous menacez quelqu'un de tomber dans la très grande précarité,
encore plus le dénigrer, que ça marche. Ça ne marche pas.
Et d'ailleurs, en France, il y a eu des études très récentes qui le montrent encore. C'était le titre du Monde la semaine passée.
Des études ont été faites sur les bases de données du Forem qui montrent exactement la même chose et toute la littérature académique le montre.
Donc, est-ce que c'est un enjeu ? Oui. Est-ce que juste dire : « Je vais revoir les incitants et augmenter la dégressivité » ? Non.
Il nous reste quelques minutes. On va peut-être parler un petit peu de ta casquette de secrétaire d'État à la Relance.
Donc, tu parlais il y a un instant des flux, hein, toute la question des flux, des véhicules, des déplacements entre les différents pôles, les différentes villes.
Il me semble avoir compris que l'Europe avait notamment eu des exigences vis-à-vis de notre politique très particulière de voitures de société en Belgique.
Comment est-ce que ça va évoluer, hein, dans les années à venir ?
En fait, l'Europe émet des recommandations pour les États membres tous les six mois. C'est ce qu'on appelle le semestre européen.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que, en fait, on nous fait croire souvent que ce que l'Europe veut absolument réformer, c'est les pensions, c'est le marché du travail, etc.
La priorité numéro une de l'Europe et ce qu'elle trouve le plus stupide dans toute notre législation, c'est le système des voitures de société.
Mmm-hmm.
Elle dit : « C'est une hérésie d'un point de vue environnemental, c'est une hérésie d'un point de vue de la mobilité ».
Donc, il fallait absolument le réformer. Problème, c'est que des voitures de société, il y en a presque un million en Belgique et qu'elles sont réparties de façon très inéquitable sur le territoire,
énormément en Flandre, où il y a une espèce de pratique beaucoup plus commune dans les boîtes d'utiliser la voiture de société.
Mmm-hmm. Beaucoup de Tesla en Flandre, hein, on se dit...
Ouais, mais en plus, c'est vrai, c'est rarement des... Non, si, il y en a, mais c'est rarement des Dacia Duster, quoi. C'est plutôt des Tesla et des BMW.
Et donc électoralement—
C'est compliqué.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que dans certains partis, c'est compliqué. Et donc je trouve que ce qui a été fait ici, parce que l'Europe, en fait, pour le plan de relance, nous a obligés de passer toute une série de réformes, y compris sur les voitures de société.
Et je trouve que la réforme du ministre Van Peteghem, même si elle n'est pas parfaite, est intéressante. De se dire : « Ce dispositif existe, comment je fais pour accélérer l'adoption de véhicules électriques ?
» Plutôt que... Bon, c'est pas parfait, parce que c'est mieux que les gens prennent pas du tout leur voiture, parce que la voiture reste un moyen...
'Fin, physiquement, c'est stupide. Souvent, les gens sont tout seuls et pour déplacer un humain de septante à cent kilos, beh, tu bouges une boîte métallique de deux tonnes.
Ça n'a aucun sens d'un point de vue physique, donc c'est pas parfait. Mais par contre, se dire : « Tiens, comment je peux faire pour,
en forçant que ces voitures de société soient électriques relativement vite, hein, dans quelques années, eh bien, je vais forcer l'adoption,
des voitures électriques, forcer la construction de l'infrastructure, etc.
» Donc, je trouve que c'est une bonne solution intermédiaire. C'est pas parfait, mais c'est une bonne solution intermédiaire.
Donc on reste dans le système des voitures de société parce qu'électoralement, c'est difficile.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas une forme de gouvernement réaliste que je connaisse qui voudrait l'abolir.
Mmm-hmm.
'Fin, je veux dire, c'était un no pass—
Réaliste électoralement, oui.
Ouais, c'était un no pasarán absolu. Quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup en politique qui s'appelle Kristof Calvo, qui est un député Groen et qui était sous la précédente législature le chef de file Groen.
Groen était très, très, très, très bon dans les sondages. On, franchement, ils étaient... Je sais plus, je me rappelle plus, mais 23, 24 %, je pense, dans les sondages avant les élections.
Et puis Kristof Calvo a tenu un discours sur la télé flamande en prime time dans un débat juste avant les élections pour abolir complètement les voitures de société avec un argument écologiste qui, honnêtement, je trouve, tient assez la route.
Et dans les deux jours, il y avait un nouveau sondage et on voyait qu'il perdait directement quelques pourcents. Et donc depuis lors, c'est un sujet qui, surtout au nord du pays et à droite, est politiquement extrêmement sensible.
Donc on a modifié profondément le régime parce que pour nous, en tout cas, il fallait pas qu'il y ait un statu quo, pour le rendre obligatoire très bientôt sur des voitures électriques et se dire : bon voilà,
ça existe, on peut pas le supprimer, donc autant en faire une arme pour
verdir les flottes plus vite.
Mh. Parmi les autres exigences de l'Europe, il y avait aussi la question de la 5G. J'ai l'impression qu'on voit tout le temps des publicités de Proximus pour la 5G.
Et puis quand on regarde la carte, c'est toujours en vert, c'est sa périphérie.
Non, c'est en plein déploiement. En fait, sur la 5G, il y avait deux questions. Et là aussi, c'est le fait de le rendre contraignant pour avoir l'argent du plan de relance, ça fait que les régions, d'un coup, se sont mises d'accord.
Il y a deux questions. Il y a les questions de normes qui sont des questions régionales où effectivement, la Flandre a été plus vite que la Wallonie sur la question.
Et puis, il y a des questions de mise aux enchères pour les opérateurs des bandes de fréquences qui dépendent du fédéral et qui, là, se sont déroulées, quoi.
La Belgique est en retard aujourd'hui, mais on devrait avoir une accélération très rapide du déploiement de la 5G.
OK, parfait. Une ou deux dernières questions et puis je vais te libérer. La question de... je sais pas si tu connais un petit peu le discours de Philippe Van Parijs—
Oui, très bien, oui.
Voilà. Et donc sa grande conviction, c'est-- parce que finalement, dans ton livre, donc, tu explores beaucoup les aspects économiques, les transferts d'argent, etc.
Mais assez peu, finalement, la question vraiment culturelle, linguistique, l'identité, etc. Lui, sa grande conviction, c'est qu'on va de plus en plus se parler anglais entre Belges.
C'est déjà ma réalité en tant que Bruxellois. Un des exemples qu'il utilise pour ça, c'est qu'il explique que concrètement, dans les allées de la chambre, entre partis politiques belges, on se parle apparemment déjà parfois en anglais.
Est-ce que c'est une réalité, ça ?
Non, dans les couloirs de la chambre, je pense pas. Mais c'est vrai que, bon, je l'ai mentionné dans plusieurs interviews, moi.
Plusieurs politiciens flamands avec qui je parle anglais. Quand tu as un francophone qui parle flamand et un flamand qui parle français, il y a une forme d'équilibre instable où en fait chacun essaie de parler la langue de l'autre.
Le plus efficace, c'est ieder in zijn eigen taal, chacun sa langue. Au Conseil des ministres, c'est comme ça parce que voilà, on se voit tellement que c'est comme ça et c'est très efficace en fait.
Mais par contre, dans des conversations avec des gens qu'on voit un peu moins souvent, etc., tout le monde essaye de montrer aussi, pour montrer qu'on fait l'effort, qu'il parle la langue de l'autre.
Donc, tu te retrouves dans des situations parfois ubuesques où moi, je me retrouve à parler flamand, quelqu'un qui me répond en français, qui est flamand, alors que c-- et là, c'est vrai que parfois, on passe en anglais.
Et moi, ça dépend vraiment de la personne, mais il y a certains politiciens flamands avec qui je parle en anglais. Quand on négociait avec la N-VA, le chef de cabinet de Bart De Wever, je lui parle en anglais.
Conner Rousseau, je sais pas pourquoi, on se-- depuis toujours, on se parle en anglais. C'est plus une question de, je sais pas, d'habitude comme ça, mais y a pas vraiment de réflexion par rapport à la langue.
Mais je pense là où je rejoins Philippe Van Parijs, que j'apprécie beaucoup par ailleurs, on se connaît assez bien,
et qui va tout à fait dans le sens de ce que j'écris, c'est qu'aujourd'hui, les enjeux bruxellois sont pas les enjeux de la Wallonie.
Aujourd'hui, effectivement, l'enjeu de Bruxelles, c'est de s'imposer comme la Babel des temps modernes, la ville la plus diverse au monde après Dubaï, qui incarne des valeurs de démocratie, de diversité.
C'est un peu la capitale du monde libre. C'est la capitale de l'Europe, c'est la capitale du monde libre dans tout ce qu'elle incarne de valeurs, de diversité, etc.
Et ça, ça doit être l'enjeu de Bruxelles. Pas de se dire : est-ce que j'ai des quotas de Flamands, des quotas de francophones dans mon administration ?
Est-ce que mon sys-- c'est pas le même enjeu que la Wallonie qui est une région unilingue
qui a entamé un long chemin de reconversion et qui doit avoir tous les leviers, y compris en matière d'enseignement, de formation et culturel, pour travailler et accélérer cette reconversion-là.
Et je pense que quelque part, on s'apprécie énormément, on a des liens énormes entre nous, etc. Mais qu'on se bloque mutuellement dans notre développement parce qu'aujourd'hui, l'enjeu de Bruxelles,
c'est celui-là, c'est d'être la rivale de Dubaï, de Washington ou d'autres grandes capitales institutionnelles internationales.
Et l'enjeu de la Wallonie est relativement différent.
Parfait. Thomas, merci beaucoup pour ces Septante Minutes Avec plaisir. Et on se retrouve très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode.
Au revoir. Je remercie encore Thomas Dermine pour cet entretien très intéressant et pour le temps qu'il m'a accordé dans son agenda très chargé.
Un agenda de ministre, c'est le cas de le dire. Je rappelle que son livre s'appelle Wallonie-Flandre, Par-delà les clichés.
Comme on disait, c'est beaucoup de chiffres, mais ça permet vraiment de s'ancrer dans la réalité économique plutôt que dans des discours très réducteurs et très polarisants.
Et franchement, ça reste très accessible quand on lit. Voilà, avis aux amateurs. On se retrouve très vite pour d'autres interviews de ministres, de chercheurs, de journalistes.
Cheers !